service kids und herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video wir spielen heute zum
allerletzten mal überhaupt nicht das
kind wir haben ganz klar drin und der
max mit dabei das ist der fall weil ich
bei hier spielen heute kran isaac ich
bin krank und ich sage ich sage hey
leute ich bin cani und ich sage wenn ich
sage auch so relativ viel aber ich darf
heute im laufe dieser aufnahme vier
dinge sagen die der liebe es heute
umsetzen muss sag mal geld muss das
umsetzen muss umsatz machen wenn du es
sagst wenn ich sage dich da muss
wirklich umsetzen müssen ich bin nämlich
bei meiner familie weil der max gestern
geburtstag hatte rangiert dir meine
kommentare falls es dann mit bisher noch
nicht gemacht was wäre liebe es sie mich
überrascht war richtig grün der max
vorher zehn jahren
ich schaffe es wahrscheinlich nicht zu
deinem geburtstag denn da muss ja der
stelle erinnern wir wohnen ja 400
kilometer auseinander
so mag sich und mag sie ja als kein ding
wenn du nicht kommst reiche meiner
mutter noch gesagt so jung damals
stellen maximal darauf ein dass ich
nicht kommen kann also damit
überraschend gut wird man maximal hälse
was kann die villen kommst und dann hab
ich natürlich reingehauen und bin nachts
um 8 von mir los gefallen kam nachts
kurz nach zwölf jahren könnte so max
komme vor die haustür
das war gut dabei wollte ich zu viel
davon erzählen denn max hat heute vier
möglichkeiten
ich will sagen damit der nicht mehr so
viel arbeit setzen wir sein gesicht war
unter spannung ja selber was ist das
caps karten aus dem augenwinkel gesehen
irgendwas schwarzes in altes audiokabel
warum bisschen bonde
okay okay als halterung
ich spiele einfach ganz normal weiter
nicht schlimm
aber genau das liebe ich einfach scheiße
vor der kamera zu machen
letzter film geschrieben so ja voll
komischer zu sehen wenn jemand sich
irgendwie so wasser rein zwängt oder so
im rahmen einer challenge und dazu
möchte ich sagen leute dass ich in einem
video nie was machen würde
mit dem ich mich nicht wohl fühle oder
so ich fühle mich tatsächlich wohl eher
so eine scheiße zu machen und mir
fucking für kabel die runterfallen der
gothika zu lassen und somit so ein
bisschen features wie sieht es gerade
aus wie so ein fußballs und
footballspieler als maxime für das
bestes palais situation für wieder raus
zu finden ja ich habe mich schon andere
taktische sachen überlegt die meisten 31
im deathmatch beziehungsweise kurz davor
aber das seerettung die regeln sind
offen dem man sich offen
es werden täglich wird das modul fertig
so starb du wirst jetzt bist du mit
diesen titel im mund nehme ja aber war
da nicht von der nachbars und dran
einmal herr wo kommt der her dass sie
dreht mega ist mir mega suspekt ich
schwöre kannst du mit endgültiger
sicherheit nicht nach und erhält nach
tennis kannst du ausschließen dass er
irgendwann hund dran war
vielleicht ja aber ich meine das ist der
nächste test und dieses tägliche haarige
zeug lief das tier vor allem günstig ich
werde einfach nur wissen dass dann kein
hund tragen kann ich leider nicht da ich
ja ok aber okay wir wollen nicht rum
diensten
diese wie christen hatten leute aller
dem hier ist echt leben kenne ich halt
geteilten 23
die sparsamkeit ich würde das
kriegsrecht einem sprecher das im tennis
palm unter mehr als ob denn schon rein
oder ich hätte hier den nicht mehr
rausgekommen ist mit roter schlucken
kann aber das sieht echt super thursday
das liebe die ich mag diese schilder vor
leute schaut man die kommentare was ihr
von dem heute in der cool wenn wir was
wir als download gibt es bei 50.000
bikes bei wievielen leiterin nein nein
okay du hast du hast zwei von vier
bisher benutzten 254 hab ich benutze
mache ich mach die nächste schon beim
beim wenn du das nächste modul erreicht
deshalb auch nicht abschalten bleibt
dran
will smith die synchronsprecher deshalb
weiter wer spricht also nicht willst mit
braucht er von praktiker 20 prozent
ok deshalb wird jetzt die nächste change
wirklich verstehen weil man dann stellt
happy ein kartenset ich jetzt ne du
wirst eine karte ziehen ich dich auch
mal anhören darf er in unterzahl ziehst
musst du so viele items wegwerfen was ja
wenn du ein bild siehst du das aber sei
die karten gebe es neun beziehungsweise
zehn ja ist es - des mediums ist jetzt
die karte die oberste du hast aber nicht
geordnet waren nicht mal die alte
durchgemischt halt so hatte ich nehme
die aber die oberste ab weil ich nicht
glaube ich bin so viel ab dass und
direkt in die kamera führte karten
du kannst auch neue wegwerfen die machen
wir macht schon sauber 10 okay 1 2 3 4 5
6 7 o
darauf kann ich noch verzichten 9
ich weiß ja und das brauche ich beides
von gold oppelt sticks an der für ne sch
wert vielleicht wenn ich noch weiß man
bekomme ein komplett wieder auf der
linken
aber eigentlich leute hatte ich mir da
ist das thema für mich aber ich muss
auch sagen semmeln bevor jetzt die hände
schmutzig macht nach jedem kiel musste
sie nämlich jetzt mit diesem
desinfektionsmittel waschen wenn ich
überhaupt ohne wird also richtig eng
es gab bisher zehnmal lieber ein
bisschen also nach jedem kill die hände
reinigen mit desinfektionsmittel steril
um das wird folgen mega bene ist es kein
machst du vielleicht war das expertin
es brennt es brennt auf der hand hatte
und jetzt sofort und dann fährst du dass
sie sich in luton auf natürlich okay
dann muss jetzt mal die hände waschen
die kassensoftware jetzt wenigstens in
uns brennt auch nicht oder
ich hasse distributionsnetz und ich
liebe des muss ja sogar das pipi schön
informiert jedoch dass sich auch richtig
aktiv aber wirklich denn partie im
krankenhaus den value spd so als diesmal
werde ich mal wieder im krankenhaus
thomas sutter durch liebe das einfach
wenn das 1 1 sodass eine wachst du das
jetzt ziehen wie viel tausend leute da
lassen wir weiterreden können okay sie
fangen also hatte ich mich für leute ihr
dürft jetzt folgende anzahl an leichter
lassen
8000 lassen der ersten zum zweiten zum
dritten weiteren das war vom heutigen
video
wir stehen alle